哦 因为我想说你那时候怎么交女朋友
就是你应该
不好说
那是前女友的故事
好 欢迎送你升红投资
那我们今天呢
邀请到的来宾
是很多人期待的这个
当冲的王者
我可以说你当冲的王之王吗
好啦 反正就因为
之前这个我们的巨人杰哥呢
他的这个
啪ポ对账单
是很吓人的这个交易量
你上次
最近一次po是几月的
七月的
七月那时候一个月就冲到
是800多亿吗
850亿
一个月冲到850亿的量
那获利也很惊人
一个月就是当时候
在行情好的时候
一个月获利就几千万这样子
而且我记得你是不是成长非常快
因为我印象中你在
我那时候第一次听到你的时候
我是听到MGK
他说你们有一个八年级生
所谓的叫少年帮
当中的一群年轻人好朋友
那他说那边有一个叫杰
他那时候就跟我说那边有一个叫杰哥的
然后一个月赚八百万
那时候就觉得哇这数字
听起来非常的厉害
可是那是二月的事嘛
对
一月
那是一月的事
一月的事
然后后来
就是在上半年的时候
行情好的时候
就不断的爆发这样子
那
对啊
运气好运气好
那因为你平常在这个
FB上呢
你的发言呢
比较少讲到你以前的
这些投资的历史啊
等等的
所以我们今天呢
就来
就是好好地聊一下
那今天不只是我啦
就是那个
杰哥的这个太太
也在旁边旁听
还有我们一位当中的好朋友俊逸
对所以待会等一下
就其他人如果想问的话
想问什么随便乱问都可以问好不好
那我们先来请这个巨人杰杰哥
介绍一下你的投资历史
你记得几岁
刚满28了
好
对我交易有17岁到现在11年了
那高三
对高三大一
因为我大学早读一年
OK
对对对
所以我17岁就大一了
所以是大一到现在
所以交易有11年左右
一开始谁带你
算是我父母亲
因为他们就有
自己本身就有投资股票
投资房地产
然后他投资股票
做不太好
然后就想说
那叫我儿子试试看
这就是起源
这怎么都特别
一般是叫儿子不要碰
因为他们就做不太起来
他们就不甘心
输给市场
对
OK
所以那你一开始
有没有谁带你
教你
没有
就是全部自学
因为他们
我父母亲家
就已经在股票市场
就是一个书家了
就是赔很多钱了
所以他们教我
也没有在教我
就是可能只带我去开户而已
所以其他的包括
所有东西都是自学
包括下单啊
什么都是自学
有所谓的老师吗
看书
也没有
就是什么书都看
那个时候就是什么书都看
然后也去听了很多老师啊
很多
很多课程
演讲都有
当时是算是11年前吗
所以是2010年
算是2010年
但是我真的买第一只股票
是2011年
因为前面有经过
那个模拟的阶段
就是你没有真正放钱进去
对
我是真正放钱进去
是2011年
你所谓的模拟是有软体吗
没有
就是看
然后跟
就是你自己心中在模拟
怎么交易这样
但是模拟过程没有很久了
大概半年左右
那时候你的模拟是指短线吗
我那时候一开始不是
我一开始是股票是做
是以波段的时候
一开始是接触的时候
不会想说当冲
因为那时候当冲其实还没有很盛行
所以那时候是以波段的角度
再开始做研究的
所以我一开始接触的商品是
其实最一开始就是股票
然后我后来接触了台指
然后选择权
然后海外的期货
海外的选择权
然后再到股期
然后最后现在又回到股票这样
所以你在2011年
你刚刚说你买了第一支的
这个股票
对
然后但是实际上
你一开始是波段交易
一开始都是研究波段
前面一两年都是研究波段
那做的怎么样
就没什么赚钱
但也没什么很大的赔钱
你那时候就大学生吗
对啊对啊
所以也没什么钱
我第一支买的股票是友达
所以我记得只买9000块
对
所以就是这样慢慢来了
那时候输赢一天也才几十块而已
几十块
你忽然让我想到
因为我以前就文章
我写过一个小弟弟的高中生
然后他现在就跟你当时一样
他也就是从几千块
现在可能有几万块
可能有超过十万块
他真的就是这样
输赢真的是
从低价股
那时候一开始没什么本钱
一定是从低价股开始练起
然后是博断交易
那时候我选择的标的
大概就是一万块以内
那其实那时候好像
那时候比现在多很多
但是主要就是面板那两支
所以那时候就是
好那我就一开始先买友达了
然后就开始做波段
那你做波段的依据是
那时候就是什么都学
所以也看了技术指标
基本上那时候就看技术指标
然后各种指标都去练
都去学这样
有课都去上
然后有书就买
所以我家里有好几百本书
OK
所以一开始
那个就是一个学习的过程
就前一两年
然后没什么赚钱
那后来呢
后来大概一两年之后
就开始知道有一个东西
叫台子期货
然后就发现
好像台子期货比较轻松一些
不用研究那么多股票
就好像只有一个指数要看
然后好像就跟现在
大部分的心态一样
就点数
只要赚几点数就可以
往上几条就可以赚几点
几点就可以乘上两百块
所以后来就开始接触台子期货
那台子期货
那就是以当冲为主
那时候就接触到很多人
就当冲
当冲很简单啊之类的
算是1314的不对
差不多1314
1314开始结束台子期货
然后技术分析
当冲的话是
当冲的话
那时候一开始接触
一定是看技术分析的
因为那时候从股票
也是只会技术分析
然后后来台子也是技术分析
然后就用技术分析
那时候也是人家的
1分K 5分K
在那边做当冲啊
就是顺势
对那时候是做顺势
那时候这样做的怎么样
我1314年
家中还是没有什么赚钱
我真正赚钱就是2015年
对
真正赚钱是2015
那15年你就算是已经毕业了
2015是我大事
大事
对对对
那时候怎么赚的
靠什么
因为那时候刚刚好有
那时候有大陆的股灾
2015年大陆的股灾
所以那时候
因为那时候
股票那时候也练了
大概三四年了
应该有四年了
所以那时候已经会
那个多了一个技巧
有時候會放空那那時候剛好會放空然後又會台子期貨所以那時候股災的時候刚才波动大然后每只股票都在跌我还记得那时候可能8月24号那一天几百只跌停板
那时候就在这个时候
赚到第一桶金
就是放空股票又当从台子起货
那个波动有够大
所以就空下来这样子
对因为那时候还是
股票的部分也是以波动为主
所以就是抱着很多空单
那我好奇问一下
你这样空下来赚到以后
那可是
其实他谈很快
我就是在
那个8月24号
跌听那天
把很多空弹都补掉
这么神
以前
那时候所以
所以越不会东西
那时候可能越
越不
懂得没有现在多
那懂得越
越没有那么多的话
反而
那时候获利看到账上
全部都跌听版
所以很爽
就去把它补掉
那以现在来说
是不可能补掉
就觉得
跌听版隔天
可能还更低啊
所以现在反而补不到了
那时候的话就是
8月24号
把所有跌停
就是补掉很爽这样
OK
那后来
所以上来那时候是没有做的
上来有
那就是狗死运
那开始
那时候2015崩盘的时候
开始接触到
可以存股
或是买金融股
所以那时候刚好在崩盘那时候
的那几天
就一直在买金融股
所以刚好那时候涨上来
金融股也有反弹
我记得有十几二十趴吧
OK
所以那时候
金融
所以那时候是股票
就是你就
那个上涨
你买了一些金融股的现股
还有0050
还有台积链
对刚刚好
就是全资股
因为那时候外面教
可能都是纯股
就是要买全资股
所以那时候就是
都是买全资股
所以后来这样靠着
这样2015年
很漂亮的做下去
又做上来以后
等于有你的第一桶金以后
做下去其实就已经有第一桶金了
就是上来可能
原本初始金额可能就几十万
那时候已经变得
也大概有两三百万左右
是
然后那时候开始2016
那时候刚刚有崩完盘
崩完盘上涨
那其实那个时候是
波动是变小的
因为就是大波动完
其实是波动是蛮小的
包括2017年也是
所以那时候我就
开始做选择权
就是那时候是做选择权的
SEO方
然后就去赚取
没有波动的权利金
所以在2016年2017年
其实我主要是靠选择权去赚
就是赚这些钱这样
你SE两边吗
对啊对啊
那时候就是流仓
但是就是很频繁的调单那种的
不是就是
不是SEO完之后就放到结算
所以是波段
可是你每天会调一下调一下这样子
对很长调啦
很长调就一直调单
就是假设靠近哪一边
你就赶快往后退
就往后退
或是加另外一边
例如那时候
因为主要是会觉得这样做
是因为就很像现在的行情
已经是量缩了
然后压缩到比较没波动
所以那时候就会觉得
做SEO方好像还不错
那你可能
他的做法可能就是
例如你下跌了嘛
你下跌你的
因为你一开始是双SE
所以你下跌了之后
你的POO有
当然一开始就有
例如sell pull加buy pull了嘛
但是如果你下跌之后
下跌之后
你的pull不是膨胀
那这个时候会去sell call
所以变成用另外一边去
也给我来锁这一边这样
然后就很多很多策略
OK所以反正
选择权其实策略就是非常非常多这样
OK就16年的时候
你应该是1617吗
就是做比较多台值的选择权
然后刚刚
包含你刚刚讲很多复合式的策略
就是这段期间波动比较小
所以我除了台智选择权以外
就开始做海棋
然后还跟海选
海棋就是当冲
那海选就是跟台湾做的是一样的
海棋是指哪一些的
例如小道小纳
清原油
或是欧洲的那种
英国时报指数
或是德国指数
你不用睡
那时候就是
到去年都还是蛮疯狂的阶段
对就比较少睡
真的假的
你几点才睡
你说现在吗
还是那时候
打海棋基本上
就一天就睡三四小时了
就是家早睡三四小时
例如你一点半收盘
那欧洲可能两点半
才开始有破洞
所以你就是睡这一小时
然后打到可能八点多
因为九点半可能每股开盘
所以你再睡那一小时
然后接下来就是打到三四点
你真的受不了的时候
才去休息了
因为海棋波动就是
这几个休息时段
是刚好没破洞的啦
那如果真的有破洞
有时候就打到五点
那五点之后再休息
然后再休息的三小时
差不多台股开盘
OK
所以那时候都是
你做那么多市场
然后可是都是短线当充
如果是海棋跟台资
那时候全部都是当充而已
那基本是顺势为
都是顺势
那这样子海棋是有赚到钱的吗
也有
那时候已经可以
海棋就是可以获利了
但是也没到很多钱
以现在来看可能就是
几十万
一两百万这样
OK
那时候认识泰台
这个是几十万是说一整年
是一整年几十万这样
OKOK
那时候还没在一起
因为我想说你那时候怎么交女朋友
就是你应该
不好说
那时候也有女朋友
那是前女友的故事
好那我是不要问了
好那所以我们时间来到1617
就是海棋跟这个台资选择权一起嘛
对
那我就很好奇啦
因为18的年初发生了一个选择权大屠杀嘛
对因为那时候我主要坐流
像是2016到2017
但是2017年
大概五六月的时候
认识了一个台湾
选择群做当冲很强的人
我称他为龙爷
他那时候就每天
在po一堆对账单
然后赚报这样
然后刚好有认识一个朋友
然后刚好有认识朋友之后
我就去请教他
就发现他做法跟我其实是类似的
但是他是
我是波段去挑单
但是他变成是
以分中委单位挑单
变成等于是卖方当冲
选择群卖方当冲
然后后来发现
他绩效也不会输我
但是我却冒惹了一个流畅的风险
那我流畅这段时间
那时候还没有夜盘
那时候其实还没有夜盘
就是我认识他的时候
是刚才刚有夜盘这样
但是那时候夜盘的成销量很少
所以那是基本上等于没有夜盘
那时候我就觉得
我流畅的风险比他大
但是我赚的钱跟他一样多
而且我们两个的本金是一样的
我记得那时候他
我差不多大概八九百万在做
他也差不多八九百万在做
那我们那时候觉得
那我是不是
我就去练练看
就是因为操作方法
调单的方法基本上是一样的
基本上只是差在那个频率
就是变成原本是用月选
那现在变成改用周选
那周选
然后以每一天就是赚取
之前可能是赚取一个月到一个月结算的那种
全力金流失的时间价值
但现在变成
对去赚开版到收盘这段的时间价值这样
OK
所以回到你刚刚
所以刚好2017年这样做
就完全的避开崩盘
到2018年那时候2月6号
那时候崩盘的时候
我就已经
那时候选择权已经算
一个月至少也打了四五万口了
所以那时候反而是
对我们来说是好做的
因为它崩盘
不是崩盘
那是散崩
2月6号是散崩
那散崩之后
那个权力期
那我还记得那一两个礼拜
那个膨胀的很夸张
因为那波动率拉很高
所以那时候就变得
每天都很好sell这样
对所以刚刚好逼开
算是蛮幸运的
像那一种一瞬间
会不敢sell吗
如果他会瞬间这样
我也不敢sell
但是以现在来看
我一定是
很干
因为那时候本金不够
没有很多啊
那就是八九百万
那时候
因为那时候还有个东西
叫spend现在没有spend了嘛现在那时候有spend那sale口数但是几百万就只能sale那几口而已而且那时候我主要是focus在周旋但是那时候2月6号其实是
都是月旋爆炸
周旋没什么爆炸
所以我们
我都没有sale到太多这样
但是有赚钱
是是是
所以我可以说你其实
现在有这些当充的这个底子
你其实是在当时
这算是基本功练很扎实
因为你基本
你用这个台资选择权
每天用日内的
一直这样挑挑挑挑
对
以这个来说是看盘会比较
比较准一些
因为你选择权要挑单
其实它很focus在现货的波动上面
你变成像打股票
可能你就会变得很熟悉
很熟悉啦
因为你那时候可能一次
看一百多只股票
去做选择权挑单
我那时候选择权的
做法主要就是看现货
看现货去做挑单的动作
看大盘还是
现货就是大盘
就看大盘
就等于是看大盘去做调单
但是可能大盘就是看各个成分股
对所以你是电脑
一幕一开是一堆全资股这样观察
对对对对
就是几百只这样在看的
然后你发现这些全资股
发现有什么异状
你就会有一些判断
对因为全资股总会有个强弱的感觉
那虽然说有点像盘感
但是其实就是
例如你看了很多全资股
那全资股它例如举个例子
它突然很多卖单
那你选择全
可能那时候台子
那时候股票还没有足笔错
那时候股票大概是五秒左右
对不对
五秒错一次
所以你现货有时候
还会领先起货
所以你会变成
你还有办法去做调单的动作
就是你发现现货在跑了
那五秒钟之内
你可以去做你的选择权
那因为那时候
你台子都还没反应嘛
所以那时候有一个时间差
可以去做赚
可以去赚这五秒的钱
所以手术是那时候练起来的吗
对
因为那个选择权卖方当中
大概一次开的旅约架
不是两只脚三只脚
那时候一次开
可能开十个旅约架
那十个旅约架
就是50点一跳嘛
所以开了十个旅约架之后
你就是做
你头脑就有点
类似十个旅约架
再去做那些组合啊
然后策略这样
然后点很快这样
对对对对
一直点一直点
对然后点很快
然后也要移动很快
哇对
这个手势
现在那个就没那么好赚
因为主笔戳
第一个是主笔戳
第二个是选择选造势变差了
因为很多期货商
开始不造势
选择选不造势
那加上
现在虽然有个东西
叫保证基金最佳化
但是也没有spand来的
保证基金释放程度
也没有spand来的好
所以加总起来
现在选择选卖方
就变得不好做了
是是是
对对对
所以也是反正
因应当时的状况
就发展出这样的策略
然后也练了手术
练了基本功
那个时候大概
你因为就觉得
每个商品都想去学学看
试试看
就是练练看这样
那我们就变成
每个商品都
其实练的时间
也不短
就是可能你专心
在一个商品赛
也练了半年一年以上
然后直到他可以获利
然后你会发现
另外一个商品好做
那你又想说
那我没关系
我就多商品多策略
那我就再多学一个商品
那就
所以一直以来
就是这样过来了
OK OK
所以刚才说到
八九百万的时候
算是在17年的年中
遇到那个叫
龙爷的算是师傅
对
他是我卖房的师傅
对 OK
选择选卖
所以他还蛮
他现在是没有活跃在网络上
因为他很低调
他现在还是赚很多钱
OK OK
然后就是跟他在网络上讨教之后
你就用了这套方法
其实蛮符合逻辑的
就是说因为你之前跟我讲过
为什么你都不留仓
因为你觉得
你还担心美股晚上怎样怎样
你不喜欢那个非掌控感
对
因为其实就是你觉得
当冲已经可以赚到钱了
那你又觉得
因为当冲其实是很累的过程
那你收盘之后
就不太想要再去烦恼
然后你美股大跌啊
或是干嘛的
所以你会
而且加上也不太可掌控
那加上你早上已经那么累
你就觉得
那都少流畅好了
所以那你
其实换成这样子以后
就是等于是跟大家学17嘛
那到18吗
就选择权的卖方
我就学一下下而已啦
因为他其实做法
跟我流畅是一样的
只是变成周旋
然后频率变得很快这样
我知道知道
那选择卖方是做到
做到哪时候
做到到现在都还有在做
只是现在变成特定时间才做而已
OK OK
对对对
现在可能变成礼拜三的结算日
那个时间价值流逝了比较多的时候
才去做选择卖方
但到现在都还有在做
那你知道
其实现在做很少了
那时候可能一个月可以做到
实际20万口
但现在一个月可能顶多1万口而已
OK
因为你这个当冲的这个调法
其实跟我们有一个朋友很像
就是草底王你认识吗
知道他
但还不认识
反正他有一些
跟这个方法非常像
所以在1718
这样子经历过以后呢
你的本金已经翻到了
超过千万了
有超过一千多
大概一千多了
OK大概一千多
详细数字已经忘记了
大概就一千多
但是换了当冲这个方法以后
你是不是开始
滴滴变得非常小
滴滴就变得
应该是说我前面的波段
因为那时候刚初学
所以他也没
就是印象的很保守
非常保守那种
那可能一个礼拜
才做一次动作
所以那时候
我已经没有把它列入
滴滴的计算
所以也不知道
那时候滴滴多少
所以真正会开始记录
交易的损益的时候
是从当中开始
就是后来的
胎子卖方在后面
在后面
那时候2018
那时候刚好
有一个商品兴起
叫股企
那时候股企开始
成交量开始放大
那时候觉得
那像那时候
有些股票叫郁金光
然后也有被动元件
那时候开始
好像股企是一个
不错的商品
所以那时候就开始去
去练股棋了
那股棋
因为股棋
因为一样是看现货嘛
我选择选与看现货
所以这个衔接点没有很
没有很长
所以马上就
股棋就可以开始赚钱这样
可是不太一样
是你以前都是
大盘的追踪大盘
但是我追踪大盘
但是大盘还是看
里面的成分股的表现
所以现在变成
之前看的是
可能十几只股票
或是一百只股票
但是现在是挑一只股票
就出来做交易
所以你
原本就已经对他有感觉了
OK
当时就是以量大为主
就是你在挑
最热门
因为那时候其实古期到
现在的成交量
古期的成交量
它已经更热弱了一些
但是那时候可能
真正有成交量的
就是那两三支而已
所以只能挑那两三支的
就是例如国具
华希腊科跟玉金光
那时候还有环球晶
大概就是这样而已
而且都是高价的国材
有成交量
比较有波动
OK
所以也是顺势当中为主
对
都是顺势当中
OK
然后反正
这样子的这个
你该不会那时候个股棋
然后你海棋都还继续做吧
对
我海棋做到去年
2020年视网膜
拨通之前都还有在做
所以他
他破洞是
不知道就突然觉得眼睛很不舒服的去检查
老实说我们就破洞了
但主要是那时候
等一下可以讲
那是去年
2020年那时候疫情崩盘的关系
所以从早打到晚
都在看着荧幕
应该是多少都有影响
今年累月这样
可是现在好了啦
那个没有好不好的问题
那就一辈子
对后遗症啊肥纹症啊这些就是一辈子的事情哦是是是那所以我们到了我们现在时间到了181918就个股期嘛
后来就是都以个股期为主
个股期为主
那时候就是
那时候18年
好像大概19年
就有那个足笔出的新闻嘛
那时候就知道2020年
要足笔出
那时候就想说
好
加上那时候已经
为那两股期
为那两已经不够我吃了
就是那时候原本
可能一开始2018打股期
可能是一口一口按
然后后来变成死狗死狗案
然后后来发现
股票已经出不掉了
但是股票是5秒
那时候还是5秒
所以我觉得股票实在太慢了
而且5秒其实也是一个
不可掌控的感觉
就是你还要等5秒
才会跳下一盘
那你有5秒
那个不可掌控感觉
那所以我那时候
就一直在等猪鼻戳
那因为最主要问题是卫纳量
那时候卫纳量
股票那时候打一打
可能占了一只
最热门的股票
成交量已经大概2-30%了
所以那时候
而且朋友加一加
大概已经超过50%了
我记得有一次玉金光
他那古旗成交了一天
好像七八千口已经算蛮
那时候的大量了啦
结果我们认识的家一家
已经少三四千口
那等于是大家都互按
那那时候就是买一下
我想要再转成现股的契机这样
所以就不够你吃
难怪你上半年
我什么那时候群状按两千口
你跟我说这样会出不掉
对啊那会出不掉
流动性风险
我那时候想说还好
像现在你现在群创
如果你是波段交易者
你那时候两千口
因为你到现在
如果你是留着
你还是两千口
但是你现在两千口是出不掉的
因为市场一冷下来
那股息会瞬间没留东西
好
所以因为量的问题
所以你从这个去年开始
就改成股票
对我就是从足笔戳
而且是3月23嘛
3月23这一天开始
我就没有下过半口股息了
应该是说就是没有
下的话可能是
想说例如自军运用
或是干嘛的
流仓之类的
那才会去下股期
但是当冲来说
就是从3月23开始
就是下现股当冲了
我蛮好奇问一下
那所以去年这样子
3月整个
因为过年整个疫情爆发
它一开盘第一天
不是先开超级低吗
对
因为你没流仓嘛
所以你没受伤
没受伤
然后一直到整个3月崩下来
然后到V转上来
你这段的损益是怎么样
狂转
还是
那时候因为
这个波动够大了
只要当充客
只要波动够大了
一定多少可以赚钱
那时候股票也是
每天跌啊
那你其实
只要做顺势
基本上很难赔到钱
但是我那时候
也有流仓台值了
就是我想说
我要做一个
流仓台值
流仓0050
有在台积点
我想说
有点在模仿
2015年崩盘的模式
就是
我就想去买一些全职股这样
所以那时候
但是
因为我那时候可能
接的时候
可能是一万
一万多点开始接嘛
一万点开始接
破一万
破一万开始接
那后来抵到八千多点
这中间当然是有
未实现的亏损的啦
不过那时候未实现亏损
因为当冲赚的钱
是cover过去
因为当冲部位比较大
但是未实现亏损
流畅部位比较小
所以是cover的过去了
所以那你就觉得迟早
不是迟早有一天
这不是赌啦
但是就觉得
我本来就是以一个
长期的角度
觉得例如
台积电不会倒
或是之类的
或是那时候研究
开始研究
我其实2016开始就有研究财报了
所以我觉得那是低于估值啊
干嘛的
那我就可以抱抱看
所以后来这方面是活力的
OKOK
然后一直到
我记得那时候买最多就是台积电跟富邦美
那时候觉得富邦美实在是一个很好的
很好的一家公司
所以那时候崩盘的时候我就一直买富邦美
你怎么会发现到它
因为我很爱用momo买东西
是你还是太太
她还是我介绍的
介绍我去
介绍她还用momo的
是哦
对对对
哇
你都买什么
很多啊
吃的也买啊
什么都买
我又觉得
Momo是一家会
真的会改变整个台湾
整个台湾电商的
的一个一家公司
因为包括他的运费的算法
或是其他的
就跟各种平台来说
虾皮
跟虾皮比
对啊
像虾皮
虾皮
因为我老婆就是做虾皮的电商
所以我会研究他的算法啦
就是包括
他是一家不会让自己
像很多
像之前的网家好了
他PC用
他是补助运费
补助到这家公司亏损
那富邦美是不会做到一件事情
因为他的运费是
所有的卖方去分担的
所以他一样让消费者
感受到免运费
但是他的运费的风险
却不是富邦美承担
而是是卖方承担
这些东西就很多他的公式
就是包括用他的财机来算
干嘛干嘛的
你觉得他们很聪明
我是觉得他基本上
他真的会改变整个生态
好好好
那所以后来
去年崩盘上来
你就是因为量的问题
就全部都做股票了
对从竹笔说
股期后来成交量比较大
但是它的标的还是有限的
那股票的成交量
一定还是比较大
所以我竹笔说之后
就是全部做股票了
我记得你是有说
你可能当天就会选
可能一只最大只的
为你的当天的
那时候后来
那时候后来量比较大的时候
变成因为你量大
可能先从量小开始讲
因为那时候一开始量比较小
就是没有可能一天顶多一亿
或是几千万
那时候是可以打很多股票的
那时候当然是会
哪一支股票有波动
就去打哪一支股票
但是后来当你量
可能差不多一支
一天大概十亿左右的时候
你会发现
一天成交量
成交值超过十亿的
有时候没行情
有才几十支了
那你不可能去占一支
成交量百分之百啊
那你就会去算那个per
percent数
那后来发现
你能打的股票就越来越少
所以说你的成交量越大
就打得越少
那就变了后来就只能打
成交值前几名的这样
对
就有啊
每次那个之前航运在那边
大家全民在封航运的时候
你就说
今天的前三名一定是我
对啊
成交量比较大
对
好
所以你后来这一段时间
就是这一年
过去这一年多
疫情之后
你就没有再打海棋了
不打海棋
因为眼睛又不能打
OK OK
因为眼睛的问题
主要是眼睛
我就是在雷射当下
因为那个雷射是很痛的
就是把视网膜黏回去
是很痛的
雷射当下
一清打麻药了还是很痛
雷射当下我就发誓
不打
不带碰海棋了
是是是
对对对
也打了好多年了
OK
所以在这一年多
你的
我可以说你的
获利就是
每个月的获利
就急速的膨胀
可以这样讲吗
刚好也是有行
刚好有行情
因为刚好有行情
所以你的量可以打比较大
那比较大
那获利
就是赚钱的情况
当然会比较多
所以可以说是说
一直往上膨胀
然后一直到
下半年量缩才停掉
这样子
对差不多八月才开始量缩掉
OKOK
好的
那这集我们
巨人节呢
跟我们分享了很多
他的投资的历史
那下一集呢
我们就来问问
看其他的问题
字幕志愿者 杨茜茜